can you think back to what some great
pieces of advice from former acting
teachers might have been I mean the best
piece of advice that most of my acting
teachers gave me was you know just to
keep to one keep pursuing it if that's
what you want to be doing you know like
do not give up on that because it's a
long hard road you know but I would say
the I said will do the question and then
I just farted all over the answer oh
it's not good oh no that was actually
the chair I did that wasn't real fine
yeah yeah no I mean probably the best
piece of advice would be to constantly
stay active to find always find ways to
keep practicing your craft and to keep
you know keep your chops out basically
if you're if you're not working on a
show or you're not doing a film get a
bunch of your friends together and do a
play reading you know like you like just
at one of your houses just to read
through that play and play that
character for the evening you know like
it really is practice and so the more
ways you can find that the more outlets
you can find to do that if you're just
getting started
community theater student films do
everything and anything you could at the
beginning you know get get experience
before you get choosy with those
experiences you know
you